where we left off in the last video we
were just kind of staring amazed at this
Earth's view of the Milky Way galaxy
just making sure we understood how
enormous and how many stars we were
looking at and even this even if each of
these dots were a star this is a huge
amount of stars but a lot of these dots
are thousands of stars our thousand
stars so this you know our mind was
already blown but what we're going to
see in this video is that in some ways
this is kind of just the beginning and
and to something we I'm going to stop
doing these these particles of sand and
the football field analogy because it's
at some point the particles of sand
becomes so vast that our our minds can't
even grasp it to begin with but let's
just start with our Milky Way and we saw
in the last video the Milky Way right
here we're sitting here about 25,000
light-years from the center it's roughly
a hundred thousand light-years in
diameter and then let's put it in
perspective of its local neighborhood so
let's look at the local group and when
we talk about local group we're talking
about the Local Group of galaxies of
galaxies so this right here is the Milky
Way's local group that's us right there
sitting right over here about 25,000
light-years from the center of the Milky
Way you have some of these small and I
use the word I use small and quotation
marks because these are all so vast
entities also unimaginable entities but
we have these satellite galaxies around
under the gravitational influence some
of them of the Milky Way but the nearest
large galaxy to us is in dromeda right
over here and this distance right over
here and now we're going to start
talking them in the millions of
light-years so this distance right here
is 2.5 million 2.5 million light-years
it just as a bit of a reference if
that's any reference at all 1 light year
is roughly is roughly the radius of the
Oort cloud and the Oort cloud was or
another way to think about it the Oort
cloud or one radius of the Oort cloud is
about 50 or 60,000 atomic and not atomic
astronomical units and that's the
distance from the Sun to the earth
so you could view this as 2.5 million
times 60,000 or so times the distance
from the Sun to the earth so this is an
unbelievably large distance we're
talking about here and that's to get to
the next big galaxy over here but even
these things are huge things with many I
mean just unfathomably many stars but
Andromeda in particular you know we said
that the Milky Way has 200 to 400
billion stars and dromeda people believe
has on the order of 1 trillion 1
trillion stars so even even even I have
you know these just start to become
numbers it's hard to grasp but we're not
going to stop here so in this over here
this this whole diagram right here it's
about 4 light years across if you go
from point to point if you go from one
side to the other side this is about not
not for light you're sorry this is 4
million light years 4 million 4 million
light years 4 light years is just the
distance from from us to alpha to the
Alpha Centauri so that you know that was
nothing that would only take a that
would only take a voyage or 180 thousand
years to get this is 4 million light
years so 4 million times the distance to
the nearest star but let's do but even
this even this is I mean I'm starting to
stumble on my words because there's
really no words describe it even this is
small on a on an intergalactic scale
because when you zoom out more you can
see our local group our local group is
right over here is right over here and
this right over here is the Virgo
supercluster
and each dot here is at least one galaxy
but it might be more than one galaxy and
this and more than one galaxies and the
diameter here the diameter here is 150
million 150 million 150 million light
years light-years so what we saw in the
local group in the last diagram the the
distance from the Milky Way to n dromeda
which was two and a half million
light-years which would be just a little
dot just like that that would be the
distance between the Milky Way and
Andromeda and
we're looking at the Virgo supercluster
that that is 150 million light years but
we're not done yet we can zoom out even
more we can zoom out even more and over
here so you had your Virgo supercluster
150 million light years was that last
diagram this diagram right over here I
want to keep both of them on the screen
if I can this diagram right here 150
million light years across that would
fit right about right about here on this
diagram so this is all of the super
clusters that are near us and once again
near has to be used very very very
loosely here this distance is about 150
this is about 150 million light years a
billion light years a billion light
years is two three four five a billion
light years is about from here to there
so we're starting to talk on fairly
massive I guess we've always been
talking on a massive scale but now it's
you need even more massive scale but
we're still not done because this whole
diagram now these are you know these
dots that you're seeing now I want to
make it very clear these aren't stars
these aren't even clusters of stars
deceive you aren't even clusters of
millions or even billions of stars each
of these dots are clusters of galaxies
each of those galaxies having hundreds
of billions to trillions of stars so
that we're just on an unbelievably
massive scale at this point but we're
still not done we're still not done this
is roughly about a billion light-years
across but right here is actually the
best estimate of the visible universe
and in future videos we're going to talk
a lot more about what the visible
universe means so if you were to zoom
out enough this entire diagram right
here about a billion light years would
fit right over would fit right would fit
just like that so we're talking about a
super a super small a super small amount
of of this part right here and this is
just the visible universe I want to make
it clear this is not the entire universe
and we say it's the visible universe
because think about what's happening
when we think about a point out here and
we're observing it and that's let's say
13 billion light years away let's say
that point 13 billion we're going to
talk more about
in future videos 13 billion 13 billion
light-years light-years and I feel
almost it's almost a sacrilege to be
riding on this because this complexity
that we're seeing here is just
mind-boggling but this 13 billion light
year away object what we're observing
where the light is just getting to us
this light left some point 13 billion
light years ago so we're actually doing
is observing that object close to the
beginning of the actual universe and the
reason why it's the visible universe is
there might have been something a little
bit further out maybe it's light hasn't
reached us yet or maybe the universe
itself will talk more about this it's
expanding so fast that the light will
never ever reach us so there's it's
actually a huge question mark it's
actually a huge question mark on how big
the actual universe is and then some
people might say well does it even
matter because this by itself is a huge
is a huge distance and I want to make it
clear you might say okay if this if this
light over here this is coming from
thirteen billion light-years away or if
this is thirteen billion light-years
away then you could say hey so
everything that we can observe or that
we can even observe the past of it the
radius is about 26 billion light years
but even there we have to be careful
because remember the universe is
expanding when this light was emitted
and I'll do a whole video on this
because the geometry of it is kind of
hard to visualize when this light was
emitted where we are in the Virgo
supercluster inside of the Milky Way
galaxy where we are was much closer to
that point it was on the order of it was
on the order of and I want to make sure
I get this right
36 million light years so we were we
were super close by you know I guess
astronomical scales we were super close
only 36 million light years to this
object when that light was released but
that light was coming towards and the
whole time the universe expanding so we
were also moving away from it if you
just think about the all of the spaces
everything is expanding away from each
other and only 13 billion years later
did it finally catch up with us but the
whole time that that was happening this
object has also been moving this object
has also been moving away from us and so
our best estimate of where this object
is now base
on how space is expanding is on the
order of 40 or 45 billion light-years
away we're just observing where that
light was emitted 13 billion years ago
and I want to be very clear what we are
observing this light is coming from
something very very very primitive that
object that object that or that that
area of space that were that light was
emitted from has now condensed and into
into way more I guess mature
astronomical structures if you take it
from the other point of view people
sitting we're in this point of space now
and they've now moved 46 billion light
years out when they observe our region
of space they're not going to see us
they're not going to see earth as it is
now they're going to see the the region
of space where earth is in a super
primitive stage shortly after the Big
Bang when I use words like shortly I use
that also loosely we're still talking
about hundreds of thousands or even
millions of years so we'll talk more
about that in a future video but but the
whole point of this video is you know I
almost it's beyond my numbing you know I
would say the last video about the Milky
Way that alone was mind-numbing but now
we're in a reality where just the Milky
Way becomes something that almost
unbelievably insignificant when you
think about this picture right here and
the really mind-numbing thing is if
someone told me that this is the entire
universe this this by itself would would
would certainly put things in
perspective
but it's unknown what's beyond it there
are some estimates that this might be
only be 1 times 10 to the 23rd of the
entire universe and we could even we'll
talk there it might even be reality that
the entire universe is smaller than this
and that's an interesting thing to think
about but I'll leave you there because I
think no matter how you think about it's
just it's just uh I don't know actually
before doing this video I stared at some
of these photos for like half an hour
this is my least productive day just
because it's just so inspiring to think
about what these dots and dots of the
dots really are